en español bueno tras la reciente
llegada de xiomara castró al poder en
honduras cuál es el impacto político que
tiene en el país este arresto
bueno la resto se está dando un contexto
donde apenas ha pasado en menos del mes
de la transición de gobierno también en
un momento donde apenas está tratando de
reconfigurar el estado luego de la
salida de ocho años del poder de juan
orlando hernández y obviamente ha tenido
un impacto muy fuerte en la población
hondureña pero también evidenciando en
la debilidad de las instituciones
públicas que en los últimos años no han
sido capaces de procesar o investigar
este tipo de señalamientos que américa
latina y el mundo lo sabíamos y los
hondureños lo sabíamos desde hace mucho
tiempo que habían señalamientos contra
el ex presidente juan orlando hernández
que como decimos recién dejó el poder no
entonces lo que nos está poniendo en
evidencia a esta situación es justamente
eso no la la fragilidad del estado de
derecho y si uno escarba en la solicitud
de arresto que ha remitido el gobierno
de eeuu estamos hablando de un periodo
gobierno de de varios gobiernos estamos
hablando de señalamientos desde el 2004
hasta el 2022 estamos hablando de 18
años en las cuales se podrían haber
estado cometiendo a estas situaciones
criminales en el país
cuéntenos reinas que están arraigados
son los vínculos en honduras entre
esferas del poder político y sectores
vinculados al narcotráfico
bueno en honduras en los últimos años se
ha mencionado que se convirtió un
narcoestado nosotros hemos visto los
últimos años como en las cortes de eeuu
han sido enjuiciados operadores de
justicia
principalmente personas vinculadas a la
policía nacional se ha librado también
solicitudes de extradición contra ex
jefes policiales también en el interno
del país
hemos observado como
muchas personas que están vinculadas al
crimen organizado operaban en el país de
manera libre
todavía todo el negocio de lavado de
activos es muy vigente y ha tenido que
venir la justicia de eeuu y ese es uno
de los temas que para nosotros es un
impacto sobre el estado de derecho
a venir a pedir la extradición de estas
personas que los últimos años han sido
llevadas a la justicia norteamericana y
como digo políticos de distinto tipo y
cuéntenos cuáles serán a partir de ahora
los pasos a seguir en este proceso
contra hernández ya que se enfrenta
potencialmente el exmandatario
bueno en este momento eeuu se presumía
que podía haber una posible fuga
entonces eeuu ha tenido que pedir como
de emergencia una solicitud de arresto
provisional en la misma solicitud se
señala que en los siguientes dos meses
se va a aportar los elementos para la
solicitud de extradición entonces
mañana se hace la presentación de el
expresidente hernández ante un juez
distancia y él tiene la posibilidad de
aceptar la extradición y proceder a un
proceso de negociaciones en eeuu o la
posibilidad de enfrentarse a una cadena
tan fuerte de una una pena tan fuerte
como la hace su propio hermano